whatup Space Cowboys goes in here for
anime uproar the response on my every
s-class hero video was amazing so I
decided to make a video about all of the
known a class heroes as well eventually
we may even get through all B Class and
C Class Heroes if you enjoy seeing one
punch man videos on this channel make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you have it be sure to subscribe
and this is really important
hit that notification bells YouTube
actually notifies you when you want
punch man videos drop if you haven't
guessed so far I will be talking about
webcomic spoilers so that I can give you
all of the relevant information now
without further ado let's jump into it
we are going to go from lowest strength
to highest strength so ironically we are
going to be starting off with the
strongest character in the entire series
the 25 year old Saitama aka cape Baldy
yes in the webcomic after the monster
association arc Saitama gets promoted to
a class rank 39 he's still far from
s-class but it's good to see him making
progress as we know Saitama can beat
almost anyone with one punch
during this video I will give ratings
from the one punch man data book when we
have them available and for Saitama we
do sytem is a physical type of fighter
and the Association gave him the
following scores a perfect tenant
stamina a won in intelligence a won
injustice a perfect tenant endurance the
perfect tenant power a 1 in popularity a
3 in effectiveness and a question mark
for fighting ability this makes this
total score about 36 out of 80 in the
hero association's eyes jenos gave
Saitama his own scores a 15 plus out of
10 and stamina a foreign intelligence a
15 plus injustice a 15 plus and
endurance a 15 plus and power a 1 in
popularity a 15 plus and effectiveness
and a 15 plus in fighting ability making
his total score 95 plus out of 80 not
bad even though it's a mathematically
impossible score it's still way more
accurate than the hero associations
final score like the most normal punches
are enough to take out most opponents in
his serious punch didn't even connect
with anything but the force from it
alone stock Boris's collapsing star
roaring cannon attack
and took him out Boros was pretty much a
god level threat since this one attack
would have blown away the planet's
surface so clearly he was a threat to
the survival of humanity yet Saitama
beat him without even connecting his
punch and Boros said that Saitama had
strength to spare so he wasn't even
going all-out with his attack thus
despite all the amazing feats that
Saitama has accomplished the true extent
of his power still can't be accurately
measured the 37th ranked hero is the 37
year old biting snake this snack just a
side note
you'll notice that we jump from rank 39
to rank 37 this is because we haven't
been introduced to some a class heroes
yet so we will skip some ranks like rank
38 however never fear we will go over
all the known a class heroes and their
powers now back to snack he's a cocky
guy who wears the suit made from the
skin of a monster he killed he's a
physical type of fighter and his
statistics are as follows he scored a 6
in stamina
a 6 and intelligence a 6 in justice a 5
in endurance a 6 in power a 5 in
popularity a 7 and effectiveness and a 6
and fighting ability making his total
score 47 out of Av snek is a martial
arts expert whose fighting style
emulates snake movements although his
biting snake fist was embarrassingly
useless against Saitama the deep-sea
King and Sulu we have to give him credit
for consistently stepping up to fight
even when he's clearly outmatched the
36th ranked hero is chain and toad a guy
who wears karate clothes has a black
belt in wears a Frog helmet on top of it
all because he's a pretty plain dude he
wears a Frog helmet to appeal to kids
since popularity is an important factor
for heroes living up to the chain in his
name karate toad man uses a metal chain
with a heavy iron weight at one end and
a sickle at the other to fight this
weapon is a traditional Japanese weapon
called a kusarigama and chain and toad
is an expert at using it he fights by
swinging the chain around using it to
hit and cut people or trap their body
parts
the 35th ranked hero is heir he's a
muscular man who does his hair in
pigtails and wears a grass skirt his
character appears to be based on
indigenous australians
he is a master at using the
a traditional weapon for Indigenous
Australians he is skilled enough to
defeat the tiger level threat black
roast with one hit the previously 34th
ranked hero was the 29 year old heavy
Kong
he is a bald tall and buff man who wears
a championship belt and a chain across
his body he also has a Mike Tyson like
tattoo on one side of his face he's in
charge of W City he is a physical type
of fighter and he scored a 5 in stamina
a 6 and intelligence a 7 in justice a 6
in endurance a 6 in power a 5 in
popularity a 6 and effectiveness and e5
in fighting ability giving him a total
score of 46 out of 80 heavy Kong fought
in armed tiger level monster called
martial guerrilla for 15 minutes on his
own and only received one visible and
shallow cut on his arm from martial
gorillas night showing he definitely
does have some skill as a fighter
however martial guerrilla was casually
smoking during the fight while heavy
Kong was panting and sweating so it's
safe to say that he was losing the fight
at that point perhaps because he was not
strong enough to overpower martial
gorilla the hero feather eventually
replaced heavy Kong as the 34th ranked
hero feather is cool and not only
because he looks like a kpop star he is
a serious dude who fights with Wolverine
like claws these blades are called tech
Hokage and they were deployed by ninja
in Japan shredder from the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles also uses these bad
boys feather is seen killing several
monsters at a time and even sweet mask
is impressed with his flair in fact
feathers fighting style is renowned
among heroes his style is called
hovering midair assassination he jumps
from one enemy to another while slicing
them with his claws and with the blades
that come out of his shoes
the 33rd ranked hero is doll master not
much is known about doll master he
appears to be a weapon style of fighter
who uses a marionette to fight kind of
like Kang Kudo from Naruto doll master
appeared in the bonus manga pork cutlet
Bowl all we know is that the puppet on
the strings actually looks less like a
puppet than the figure controlling the
strings and even the hero Association
does know who is the master
and who is the puppet the 32nd ranked
hero is shadow ring she is a female
ninja from an unknown village she's
actually really awesome and uses
substitution jutsu like in Naruto so
that the monster thinks they hit her
while they actually only hit a log
substitute she then goes on to expertly
decapitate the monster with a swipe of
her sword she even impressed his flashy
flash with her ninjutsu no easy feat
however she still has a ways to go since
she couldn't do anything against the
demon level monster rhino wrestler the
31st ranked hero is forte he is actually
hilarious he's a young dude who wears
glasses a hat a hoodie and most
importantly headphones I laughed so
badly when he challenged sight them up
to a fight in chapter 98 of the webcomic
Forte listens to music when he fights
and builds his fighting style around the
rhythm of the music it's definitely a
unique fighting style that has somehow
gotten him pretty far but there are
major drawbacks because his music is so
loud he can't hear what's happening
around him so before he can fight
Saitama he gets hit by a car because he
couldn't hear the honking after the car
hits him he's out cold inside to my
warns him about the dangers of listening
to music in the middle of a fight I
can't wait until the manga and anime
catch up to this part so I can relive
this hilarious moment once again the
30th ranked hero is peach tere he can be
identified by his headband which has an
image of a peach on it he is a weapons
type of fighter and uses a katana in
battle we are told that his biggest
weakness is talking too much during a
fight
in the bonus manga chapter lost cat he
was no match for the demon level monster
Grizz meow who absolutely terrified the
peach swordsman the 29th ranked hero is
narcissus stoic you can recognize this
hero by his amazing hair his long chin
and the rolls that is in his mouth at
all times
leaning less toward stoicism and more
towards narcissism this hero can be very
arrogant showy and flamboyant he tells
sweet mask to behold the sheer elegance
of his beautiful combat arts and then he
goes on to perform his move soft touch
execution ironically despite the name of
the move and the elegance he's going for
his moves are definitely not pretty
look at he throws his rose into the air
then brutally punches a monster several
times these another one in the stomach
and finishes a third off with a
cinderblock before catching the rose he
threw in his mouth he shows that his
attacks are definitely powerful but
they're far from beautiful sweet mass
doesn't even pay any attention to him
and instead appreciates feathers much
more graceful fighting style as we saw
narcissus stoic is primarily a physical
type of fighter but he'll definitely
stoop to using surrounding objects like
a cinder block or his rose gold brass
knuckles if he needs to the 28th ranked
hero is the 47 year old spring mustachio
between his suit bowtie and moustache
you can't deny that this guy has style
mustachio is a weapons type of fighter
using a fencing style of sword that can
do cool things like coil extend and more
he scored a 5 in stamina a 6 and
intelligence a 7 in justice a 5 in
endurance a 7 in power a 5 in popularity
a 6 in effectiveness and a 6 in fighting
ability meaning he scored a 47 out of 80
overall well stash heel can easily slash
through concrete and metal but he can't
beat the tiger level monster combo
infinity to his credit though he did not
scream out like the monster hoped he
would mustachio was also noble enough to
come to Golden Balls rescue when
garlotte act him but garu ended up being
too much for him to handle the 27th
ranked hero is the 26 year old smile man
he is the highest ranking member of the
surely brothers followed by crying man
and then angry man you can recognize
this hero by the smiley face on his
chest
he's amazing at keeping his cool and
even remain calm when a demon level
monster jumped out and punched him smile
man used a kendama in battle which is
based off of a traditional Japanese toy
it looks like a giant two-sided hammer
with a smiley face on top his secret
moves are all based on tricks with the
kendama for instance the smiley face on
top can grow in size and be sent flying
at the enemy unfortunately he was still
nowhere near Garros level when they
fought the 26th rank hero is the 28
year-old golden ball with his baggy
pants and hoodie
he's the last person you'd expect to be
partnered with the classy mustachio but
the two do make a great team
he's an overconfident dude who doesn't
think he needs to prepare for a fight
he's a weapons type of fighter and uses
a slingshot a laser pointer and
shape-changing golden bullets in battle
he scored a six in stamina
a five and intelligence a six in justice
a six and endurance a six in power a
five in popularity a six in
effectiveness and a six in fighting
ability meaning he scored a forty six
out of 80 overall his bullets can pierce
steel and he was skilled enough to wound
Garland's leg
however gara just to the speed of his
bullets and after he runs out of ammo
Golden Ball is pretty much powerless the
25th ranked hero is Crescent I brawl you
can recognize him by the crescent moon
on his helmet and chest he fights with a
crescent-shaped blade and he is strong
and fast enough to slice multiple
monsters in quick succession like most a
class heroes Crescent eyebrow was no
match for the demon level monster Rhino
wrestler the 24th ranked hero is Green
who has a very unique ability that is
not based on superhuman strength or
psychokinesis he can control plants
growing out of his body and use them to
bind monsters he can constrict them
until they die or trap them so other
heroes can finish them off green looks
pretty feeble because the plants growing
inside his flesh needs so many nutrients
in 22nd place we have one shot
appearance-wise you just don't get much
cooler than a sniper with a cybernetic
eye patch and a turtleneck he pulled off
the super cool feat of shooting through
an enemy monsters bullet and the bullet
even ended up going right through the
monsters sniper scope and hitting it in
the eye
he acts cool until a sniper jams and
then he freaks out and begins to panic
like many weapon style fighters he is
relatively powerless without his weapon
when a champs he even goes as far as the
high behind pooty pooty prisoners legs
like a child and with that his cool
image fell apart
unfortunately the 19th ranked hero is
the 21 year old lightning max the guy
who walks around with a lightning symbol
on his left cheek he may have got his
butt kicked by the deep-sea King but to
his credit he kept fighting until he was
out
cold he's a weapons type of fighter and
scored a six and stamina a five and
intelligence a six and justice a five
and endurance a seven empower a six in
popularity a six and effectiveness and a
six in fighting ability giving him a
total of forty seven out of 80 max
mainly fights with his lightning shoes
which have gunpowder stored inside them
the shoes contain among other things
boosters detonation switches and iron
plates so that he can dramatically
increase his speed and attack power max
is a martial artist and uses hyper
karate style which revolves around
karate kicks the 17th ranked hero is the
24 year old lightning Genji a guy with a
Bane like mask on his face and roller
blades on his feet
lightning Genji was in charge of D city
and he rose to a class quickly after
joining the hero Association despite
this he couldn't beat the two tiger
level monsters mycoplasma
and electric catfish who also have
lightning slash electricity based powers
Genji is a weapons type of fighter and
he scored a 5 in stamina
a 5 and intelligence a 6 in justice a
six in endurance a 7 in power a 6 in
popularity a 6 and effectiveness and a 7
in fighting ability making his total 48
out of 80 he fights with two stun rods
his attack max electricity allows him to
release maximum voltage output from his
stun rods for maximum damage but my
favorite thing about Genji has to be the
fact that he wears roller blades in
battle I love that the 16th ranked hero
is butterfly DX
he is a hairy hero who walks around
shirtless he only wears a thong
high-heeled shoes jive butterfly wings
and a headband with butterfly antennae
he fought the demon level monster
multi-eyed octopus but he was no match
for it we don't know much else about
butterfly DX but it appears like he can
use his wings to fly or at least get
some impressive airtime the 13th ranked
hero is great philosopher one of my
absolute favorite heroes he has a long
white beard like an ancient Greek
philosopher and yet he's jacked like
Arnold Schwarzenegger in his prime as if
he couldn't get more epic he carries a
huge book on him his alias is great Iron
Man's
take that regular Ironman being the
philosopher he is he tries to understand
monsters he asked them about their
feelings and motives but they don't give
him a real response so he kills them
with his book when child emperor's
scanned him to see how powerful he was
he got an impressive 2442 a much higher
score than the higher ranking a class
heroes stinger who only got 1600 if we
should take away anything from this
character it's the value of books you
can read them in your leisure time and
use them as weapons in life-threatening
situations knowledge is power
the 11th ranked hero is twin-tail a
Harley Quinn looking hero her name
twin-tail comes from her pigtail hair
style I think she has to be one of the
best hero designs she dresses like a
jester with a blindfold and a teardrop
painted on her left cheek her pigtails
are also held up by specific dice that
each have the number 4 on all six sides
the number 4 sounds like the word death
in Japanese so it's kind of like saying
to her enemies your only outcome is
death which is pretty cool she juggles
deadly weapons like blades heavy balls
and bowling pins that she can use to
kill multiple monsters simultaneously
twin tails is clearly a weapons type of
fighter and actually has over 30 weapons
hidden all around her body the 10th
ranked hero is the 24 year old stinger
who reminds me of Lancer from fate/zero
it's probably because of the hair tight
clothing and spear he is proud
charismatic overconfident and as a
result hilarious
he beat 10 monsters on his own who
together were around a threat level
Tiger now that is pretty impressive but
he overestimates his accomplishment
after he defeats them he says I did it I
did it
did I just single-handedly beat a god
level innovation I'm so awesome I love
his positivity but in truth stinger is
not even a match for a demon level
monster like deep sea king when he shows
up stinger is a weapons type of fighter
and he scored a 6 and stamina a 5 and
intelligence a 7 injustice a 6 and
endurance a 7 in power a 7 in popularity
a 6 and effectiveness and a 7 in
fighting ability in other words he
scored a 51 out of 80 he can spin his
Spears
head and use it like a drill to
completely rip through an enemy he can
even use the spinning of his spear to
launch himself into the sky like a
helicopter and it probably won't
surprise you that one of his favorite
hobbies is taking care of his hair the
9th ranked hero is tank top vegetarian
another amazing name for a hero tank top
vegetarian is second-in-command of tank
top masters tank topper army his name
comes from the fact that he believes in
the power of the tank top and
simultaneously in a healthy vegetable
based diet he's a physical type of
fighter like his master and he scored a
six and stamina a three and intelligence
a five injustice a six endurance a six
in power
a six in popularity a six in
effectiveness and a six in fighting
ability so his total score was a 44 out
of 80 tank top vegetarian may well be
the second strongest member of the manly
tank top or army but he was absolutely
no match for Garo who defeated him along
with the rest of the army the 8th ranked
hero is death Gatling this cool-looking
dude has a Gatling gun in place on his
left arm and a lot of belts even large
hordes of monsters don't pose a threat
to him because of his efficient use of
his gun which shoes faster and has
larger rounds than a normal Gatling gun
although taking out higher ranking
monsters is not so easy for him for
instance he is no match for the
so-called human monster Garo death
Gatling is actually upset that S Class
Heroes get so much attention and that
excellent heroes outside of the S Class
go practically unnoticed this is why he
assembled a group of a class heroes to
defeat Garo who has a reputation of
being able to defeat as class heroes
death Gatling wants to prove that a
class heroes aren't meaningless but
unfortunately his obsession with being
recognized only leads to his defeat the
7th ranked hero is magic trick man a
hero who looks like a cross between a
magician and the Riddler from Batman
however he is super serious and hates
criminals according to the data book his
ability type is secret which is fitting
for a magician he scored a 5 in stamina
a 6 and intelligence a 7 in justice a 6
in endurance a 6 in power is 6 in
popularity a 6 that
this and a seven in fighting ability
totaling up to a forty nine out of
eighty his battle style pretty much
consists of using magic tricks and tools
in battle his cane can spread smoke
across the battlefield in order to blind
opponents he can release birds who can
see past the smoke to attack his enemies
he also keeps sharp playing cars that
can cut an enemy
despite his versatility and mystery like
most a Class Heroes he is no match for
Goro the six strength hero is the 19
year-old blue fire who can be seen
rocking a dark blue kungfu suit as his
name suggests he fights by shooting blue
flames at his opponents he's serious
strict and does not value the life of
criminals he fired an attack at Garo
while criminals were standing behind him
and at risk of getting hit thus when
Gaara he ended up cremating some
criminals he was no match for Garo who
revealed that blue fire uses a portable
flamethrower inside his sleeves to fire
his blue flame attacks he's obviously a
weapons type of fighter and he scored a
5 in stamina a 6 and intelligence a 7 in
justice a five in endurance a six in
power a seven in popularity is seven and
effectiveness and a seven and fighting
ability all totaling two a 50 out of 80
don't let his powerlessness in the face
of garrulous lead you he is a very
powerful hero and Stitch the ministry
officer of justice for the hero
association even said that blue fire is
comparable to as class in terms of
fighting ability the fifth ranked hero
is the 35 year old heavy tank loincloth
a man with one of the most epic
mustaches I've ever seen I mean it's
like he has two boomerangs hanging out
of each nostril
he also towers over most people he's
seven feet and seven inches tall and
weighs over 270 pounds and he appears to
be completely naked except for a
loincloth he is an aggressive dude who
follows his own code of honor yet
despite all this Gaara takes him out
with a punch heavy tank loincloth is a
physical type of fighter he scored a six
in stamina
a six and intelligence a seven in
justice a six and endurance a five in
power a five in popularity a six and
effectiveness and a seven in fighting
ability making his total score 40
out of Av he is strong enough to knock
out thugs and even break through
concrete with his fists but he may break
his arm in the process he's pretty much
nappa from DBZ in appearance and in
level of usefulness the 4th ranked hero
is the 37 year old Russia drill a
disciple of atomic samurai Russia drill
looks like a stereotypical samurai and
has very wild and bushy eyebrows he is
the oldest of atomic samurais disciples
and thus acts like the wisest he is
conscious and warns the others like ein
when they're acting reckless he's a
weapons type of fighter and he's 47 in
stamina if I'm an intelligence he's
seven in justice a 7 in endurance he's 7
in power a 6 in popularity 6 and
effectiveness and an 8 in fighting
ability making his total score a 53 out
of 80 his weapons of choice are special
katanas that are shaped like drills
there are smaller blades inside the
katanas that can pop out and spin adding
destructive power to his attacks the
third ranked hero another disciple of
atomic samurai is a 26 year old okema
Itachi this hero has a Pikachu look
going on and is an amazing swordsman
welcome I Tasha can use the curved
katana to send huge blades of wind at
the enemy this attack is so impressive
that EIN says that the technique looks
like the work of gods every time he sees
it
welcome my touch is obviously a weapons
type of fighter and scored a 7 in
stamina a 5 and intelligence a 7 in
justice a 6 and endurance a 7 in power a
6 in popularity a 6 and effectiveness
and then 8 in fighting ability making
the total score a 52 out of 80 I must
say the ability to send sharp blades of
wind at an enemy using nothing but a
sword is one of the most unique in the
series and one of my personal favorites
let me know what your favorite ability
in one punch man is in the comments the
second ranked hero is the 23 year old
iron also translated as a I rod yet
another atomic samurai disciple and his
top disciple too so yeah atomic samurai
is clearly a skilled sensei since he has
three powerful and high ranking students
iein has a katana but interestingly
enough he wears medieval armor made out
of iron when he fights he has the
fastest swordsmanship skills out of all
of a top
samurais disciples he is quick tempered
and can be overconfident like the rest
of the samurai disciples he's a weapons
type of fighter and he scored a seven
and stamina eight five and intelligence
B seven injustice a six and endurance a
seven empower a six in popularity he's
six in effectiveness and an 8 in
fighting ability making his total score
a 52 out of 80 additional credit goes to
EIN for losing his left arm to a dragon
level monster without even screaming out
and for being able to stop a demon level
Rhino wrestlers charge when a bunch of a
and B Class Heroes could not and finally
we get to the first rated hero the 24
year old handsomely masked sweet mask
not only is he a strong hero he is a
famous model actor and singer he is the
most popular hero in the world in fact
in the world of one punch man he ranked
number one in the popularity polls for
28 weeks in a row he has blue hair and
yellow eyes that appear to turn red when
he is angered as his name suggests he
has a darker side beneath his sweet mask
he hates evil and is merciless when it
comes to exterminating it he even killed
a caveman that the hero association
specifically asked him to bring back
alive he is a physical type of fighter
who scored an 8 and stamina a 7 in
intelligence and impressive 8 injustice
a 7 in endurance and 8 in power a 10 in
popularity a 9 and effectiveness and a 7
in fighting ability making for a total
score of 62 out of 80 to put this in
perspective pooty pooty prisoner and
s-class hero only scored 56 out of 80 so
a 62 is very impressive despite being a
class we are told that sweet mass is
worthy of s-class he has shown that he
can even face a disaster level dragon
monster like furor ugly and come out of
it with no significant damage which is
very impressive considering that all of
the other a class heroes have trouble
fighting with demon class monsters like
rhino wrestler sweet mask loves his fans
justice missions and skincare products
and he hates evil annoying interviews
and irresponsible heroes and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watch
make sure to smash that like button if
you enjoyed this video and want to see
more like it thanks again for the insane
response on the S Class Heroes video I
truly did not expect that let me know
what other one punch man videos you
would like to see in the comments a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King's August and Angel
Cruz and other one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans baby ray a
seventeen ffvp
Steven and Greta a Lola autumn Maddie
Mac 239 makoto-kun and Keylong and the
patrons who transcend greatness itself
Regan Harrison and Lord Noxon or the
chosen few who have been acknowledged by
Lord we go himself if you enjoy our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon calm an Emir and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these real-life heroes right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patient only discord so check out
patreon calm animals or link in the
description if you're interested and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]